pyramidale conique cylindrique ou encore
hexagonal sophie fourmaux khrenov près
de 300 abat jours par mois des créations
sur mesure grâce aux quelques 5000
références de papier japonais ou népal
et en sa possession à clients peuvent
venir nous voir avec un pied et en
fonction de la taille du pied de sa
forme je lui ai proposé différentes
formes d'abat jour et ensuite le client
il n'a plus qu'à choisir le papier qui
lui convient
[Musique]
là-bas juriste a participé au concours
en 2020 lauréate de la compétition elle
revient sur son parcours c'était une
très bonne expérience parce que du coup
ça permet de mettre à jour son dossier
son business model sa son ambition de
mettre tout à plat et surtout après il
ya donc le fameux pitch affaire devant
une trentaine de jury on a un pitch
affaires de 7 minutes et ensuite il ya
sept minutes de questions donc c'est une
expérience que je ne connaissais pas
avant mais j'ai appris à le faire avec
créatrice d'avenir sophie fait toujours
partie du réseau créatrice d'avenir elle
souhaitait accroître son entreprise et
l'expérience a porté ses fruits
ça m'a apporté énormément de notoriété
de la crédibilité à mon projet pour
trouver des financements est également
ça m'a apporté pas du business ça a
permis d'avoir une forte augmentation du
chiffre d'affaires grâce à ce concours
suite au concours l'activité de
l'abat-jour east s'est développée
aujourd'hui elle est accompagnée d'une
apprentie pour le côté commercial à qui
elle transmet les ficelles du métier une
ligne de bagagerie week end arrivera en
2022 comprenant sac est rousse
[Musique]